In the collective memory
of the People Diana,
Princess of Wales was
everything rolls should be.
She was beautiful,
composed and full of
compassion for those in need,
and when did she died?
In 1997.
It was a horrific tragedy
that shook the world.
She had been robbed of a future that was
looking incredibly bright and our sons
would forever be without a mother,
but the dark secrets of
Diana's life proved this.
All that glitters is not gold.
Some people believe that her death was
no accidents and there was actually an
elaborate conspiracy designed by the
royal family to silence in the biographics
video today we look at
Diana Princess of Wales.
Dan was born on July the first 19,
61 to John and Francis Spencer.
It had been a tradition for members of
the inability to marry one another for
centuries and her parents
were no exception.
Together with her two older
sisters and two brothers,
they lived in a mansion called
Park House in north England.
As you can imagine,
Diana grew up with the best things that
money could buy and she went on play
dates with children in the royal family,
but all of the money in the world
can't buy happiness drawn in Francis.
They had a toxic marriage mold her life.
His parents never said,
I love you to one another
or indeed to their children.
They pushed off most
of the parental duties.
Do Nannies or governesses at age nine,
her father sent her to boarding school.
Her mother remarried to a
man called Peter Shand kid,
who was the ad who is
successful wallpaper company.
Her father married a woman
named rain mccorquodale,
who was the daughter of a
famous romance novelist.
The children,
they weren't present at their second fall,
this marriage,
and they have to find out
about it through the newspaper.
Diana to siblings deeply resented rain
as an evil stepmother and blames half a,
tearing the family apart.
Diana was a shy girl and
she struggled in school.
She was labeled as the thick one by her
family and this was enough for her to
ends up crying in school.
Every time she got a bad grade,
deep down,
all she really wanted was to be loved
and accepted for who she was and dreamed
of a prince who was going to take her
away so she could live happily ever after.
When she was just 16 years old,
Diana met Charles the Prince
of Wales for the first time.
He was 29 and dating
her older sister Sarah.
The relationship between
Sarah and Charles,
it never went anywhere,
so they went their separate ways.
However,
Charles said that Diana
made a big impression on him
because he thought she was
very cheerful and beautiful
when she came of age.
Diane,
I could have chosen to party
like a socialite or travel
the world with a family
as well,
but when she was eating,
she chose the very normal life of
working as a kindergarten teacher.
She used her paychecks to Sharon
apartment with a few friends that I loved
taking care of children,
and it made her very happy to give them
the love and the encouragement that she
never got as a little girl at that time,
Diana was filled with a lot
of hope about our future.
She said that she felt this deep sense
of destiny and one day she would grow up
to do great things.
Prince Charles had been dating
several women over the years,
including Camilla,
Rosemary Shan's.
Camilla was not wife material
in the eyes of the Queen,
so she married a multimillionaire
named Andrew Parker Bowles.
Charles and Camilla never actually
broken off that relationship and they
continued having a secret affair the
entire time that she was married.
Charles was now in his thirties and under
lots of pressure from his mouth as he
settled down and produce an APP,
he needed a wife that was a member of
the aristocracy and Diana had all of the
qualifications of a perfectly
acceptable bright off going on.
Only 13 dates.
Charles proposed to Diana when
she was a belly legal 18 year old,
even though they hardly
knew one another to nfl,
says the becoming the princess was
the sense of destiny that she had been
waiting for all along a couple
of weeks after their engagement.
The couple was interviewed by the press.
Towards the end of the reporters said
that they were very much in love.
Dan replied,
of course,
Charles Loft saying whatever in
love means watching the tape.
You can clearly see that Diana was
heartbreaking and later interviews,
Diana defines that instance,
is the moment she knew that marrying
him would be a huge mistake.
However,
the entire world had their eyes on
her and she knew it was her duty to go
through with the marriage.
Even to this day diner and Charles still
go down in history for having one of
the most expensive weddings.
Experts estimate that today that
wedding would cost anywhere from 70 to
$100,000,000.
From the perspective of the
people watching the wedding on tv,
it seems like a dream come true.
Diana later said it was the West staff.
My life.
The honeymoon was on the
royalty entrepeur Tanya,
Diane,
and reportedly spent most of
the time sleeping in 1982.
Charles and Diana had been married for
less than a year and she had already
discovered Charles is secret
relationship with Camilla Parker Bowles.
He started to gaslight her
saying that she was paranoid.
This made half so devastated that
she threatened to kill herself.
Joel is ignored her and started to
leave to go on a horseback trip.
Diana threw herself down the stairs.
The Queen rushed our aid screaming for
a doctor while will love the attendance
around at the princess.
Joel's just kept on walking
to the outside world.
The marriage between Diana and Charles
seemed like a fairytale that comes to
life for the first time.
People around the world were fascinated
and invested in the royal couple.
The Massa,
what was going on behind closed doors.
She had to smile,
wave and just pretend
that everything was fine.
Diana was still just a teenager when she
was put under pressure by the media to
be this perfect princess
combined with a healthy marriage.
It was enough to make a spiral into
a deep depression and she became.
She had so much empathy for other people.
That's a particularly difficult meeting,
visiting the pole sick and we
Beta mental health a lot worse.
Instead of recognizing
that she needed help,
Diana was treated like a child throwing
a Tantrum and the royal family just
continued to ignore her issues.
William was born when
Diana was 20 years old,
just barely out to that teenage years.
She was to raise the future king that's
a William Reuter loss of joy and purpose
to our life during interviews.
That press would mostly ignore
how while they spoke with Charles,
asked Diana how the baby was doing,
even though this was actually
very demeaning to Diana's face,
would light up and she would gush about
how much fun she was having with him.
Even officer giving birth to the.
Our relationship with our husbands
remains coles and distance.
She eventually decided that if she
was going to be stuck in an unfaithful
marriage,
she would have an effect too.
When she was 23,
Donna fell in love with a cavalry
officer named James Hewitt.
They went together about a year before
how second some Harry was born in
pictures showing the two
of them side by side.
It is easy why people believe that James
Hewitt might actually be Prince Harry's
biological father.
This is such a popular theory that it was
even turned into a stage play that was
performed on the west end.
Diana pushed Charles to be more involved
in raising the boys instead of relying
totally on Nannies.
When the boys were old enough to go out,
she made sure they had normal
experiences like waterparks,
Mcdonald's,
and shopping.
She also brought them to homeless
shelters to pass out hot tea and food.
Prince Charles,
he scoffed at these ideas and asking why
all of that was necessary when she was
25.
Diana fell in love with her bodyguards.
Barry Maliki.
They became best friends and
she felt very safe around him.
April's lots of joy to our life,
but Diana claims that they
never actually crossed the line.
However,
most people still consider this to be an
emotional affair or at the very least,
once their friendship was revealed.
Prince Charles Five Medicaid,
no long enough to anything.
His job at the royal palace
sparing anarchy was killed
in a motorcycle accident.
Charles and Diana were on their way to
the con film festival in France when he
told her the news.
Charles mentioned many death so casually.
It was as if he was
talking about the weather.
Diana wanted to cry there.
She knew that within a few moments you
would have to step out of the car and to
be photographed by hundreds of people,
so she had to put on that smile once
again and just pretend like nothing was
wrong.
She and I just said,
I think he was bumped off,
but we'll never know.
Diana felt that if she did
not escape the marriage,
she really might want
to take her own life.
She knew that her only hope of getting
a divorce would be to get the public on
her side.
It was at this point that she decided
to speak with a journalist named Andrew
Morton about the truth of the
dysfunctional household motion.
Eventually published her
biography called a Diana.
Her true story in her own words,
for the first time in history,
the public got a glimpse into
the life of a royal marriage,
says certainly wasn't prissy.
Charles responded by being interviewed
for a documentary in 1994 called trials
the private man,
the public role where he admitted
he had an affair with Camilla,
Parker Bowles.
Lana responded by doing an
interview on BBC Panorama in 1995.
During this interview,
she said that she believed Charles was
not a good person and he wasn't even fit
to become the next king
of the United Kingdom.
She believed that her son,
William would do a much better job serving
the people Diana said of herself that
she wouldn't go quietly
saying that's the problem.
I'll fight to the end.
Diana and Charles were separated for
years and seeing other people off to the
bickering back and forth in the media.
The Queen herself demanded that they
needed to officially get divorced.
In 1995,
Diana began dating and
Egyptian millionaire named
dirty Fiat is falling though
was the owner of these successful
Harrods department store runs,
has the net worth of one
point $6,000,000,000,
which by the way is far
richer than the queen.
Charles and Diana were
officially divorced in 1996.
Jobs would eventually go on to marry
his longtime girlfriend is going to the
pocket bowls even after leaving.
Her position is Princess of Wales at
wanted to continue her destiny by making a
difference to the world.
She was pretty terrible
at public speaking,
which really was necessary during
charity events and public appearances,
so she started to receive vocal
lessons from a former actor named Peter
settlement during the lesson settled and
set up a camera to record her progress
and you asked her questions
about her personal life.
These became much needed
therapy sessions for her.
She revealed secrets about her marriage
and the royal family through these
lessons with sas alone,
and she was able to find her own voice
and learn to thrive as a public speaker
after her death.
These tapes were confiscated by the royal
family and the public were not able to
see them until years later.
Diana,
she became a traditional celebrity
without the benefit of royal security.
The you continued to follow her and
write about her in the tabloids.
Instead of allowing the press do you
only write about her hair and fashion
choices,
she decided to make the best of being
in the spotlight by getting involved in
causes that matter tat she
raised awareness about the
aids epidemic and travel
to several African countries to fight
for the ends of landmines and public
spaces.
One of the most famous photographs of her
was with a young amputee who had had a
leg blown off almost immediately after
getting the attention of the press,
the laws,
amount,
landmines.
They were changed.
However,
this was making lots
of politicians unhappy.
They said that she was getting involved
in issues that she didn't fully
understand how response was that she
really didn't care she was going to fight
for the people and not the politicians
instead of wilting into quite obscure.
He,
Diana,
she was thriving.
She was no longer depressed.
She was glad to trade her
title for a life of freedom.
She auctioned off all of our designer
gowns and gave millions to charities that
she cared about all of this,
and you made the public love her more and
she was still a princess in the hearts
of the people.
Often her divorce was finalized.
Diana was dating an Egyptian
man named doody fired.
He was a multimillionaire.
He lived a very glamorous life,
pepper add,
see took photos of them on
vacations around the world,
the British press schools in a playboy
and write negative connotations about the
fact that he was Muslim.
He was actually a successful movie
producer who was best known for the Oscar
winning movie starring Robin Williams.
It was also the RTD multibillion
dollar Harrods department store.
Fortunate.
The two of them were very much in love
and they plans on Sunday getting married.
Some even believe that Diana may
have been pregnant with his child.
If this was true,
it would have cost a lot of
issues for the royal family.
The idea that William and Harry,
you could have a Muslim half sibling.
It was unacceptable.
She was also threatening to reveal more
and more secrets about the royal family
to the press or charity work as well.
It often interfered with money making
schemes among the inability indeed she
even received death
threats on a regular basis.
Not long before her death.
Diana wrote a letter to a Butler saying
that she believed her ex husband Charles
was trying to have are
killed in a car accident.
She also cold duties.
Father Mohammed all fire
engines told him the same thing.
On August the 31st 1997 dirty Fiat and
Diana were being driven through Paris on
that named Henri poll,
just as they entered the alma tunnel.
They were apparently running from pepper,
etsy and ended up in an accident.
For whatever reason,
every single one of the security cameras
inside the tunnel just so happens not
to be working that day.
So there is no recording
showing exactly what happens.
According to witnesses,
the car went into a pole at 65 miles per
hour and no one was wearing a seatbelt.
On September the sixth,
19,
97.
The streets of London where
lines with people moaning,
Princess Diana's death.
Millions do.
You didn't watch the
funeral procession on TV.
They're all cortel to trial and found
that the crash was simply an accident.
However,
everyone present at that
trial was obligated,
decide with the royal
family and that findings.
Many people think they
were totally biased.
However,
in 1999,
the French government also investigated
the car crash and they came to the same
conclusion.
It was simply an accident.
However,
in 2008 and new independent investigation
found that the driver Henri Pool had
been drinking heavily that day and the
original trial had failed to mention that
they also concluded pepper add,
see vehicles.
In fact,
tailgating the calm,
the jury concluded that Henri Paul was
responsible for the deaths and that if he
was still alive,
he would be convicted of meme set.
For some,
this investigation was not enough
and one of those people was Dodi's.
Father Mohammed are fired.
He had spent years of his life
struggling with racism while running his
business,
and he was disgusted by how
the media is portraying Dodi,
even though he was a victim to Mohammad.
All five claims that he had evidence
for 175 separate conspiracy theories and
paid for a documentary called
unlawful killing to cover them all.
Obviously in this video we call him
go too deep into all of the conspiracy
theories,
but it was enough for the
British government to ban
the documentary from being
seen in the United Kingdom.
According to these conspiracy theories,
Henri Paul was actually sober that day
because the receipts from the hotel
showed that he only had two drinks at
dinner and had gone through a medical exam
by security beforehand.
He had actually outrun the pepper
ratzy and mysterious wide Fiat,
you know,
followed them into the tunnel
with a group of motorcycles.
Some believe that these were on my
six agents who were being paid by the
government to kill her.
After inspecting the cola,
they discovered that the seatbelts and
honorary pols car had been tampered with,
which is why no one was wearing them.
It also took over an hour and a half
for the ambulance to get to the hospital
even though they were very doctors,
believe that if Diana was wearing his
seat and into gotten medical attention
sooner,
she would've survived.
Unfortunately,
without videotape of the crash,
we may never know the whole truth of
the circumstances surrounding her death
today,
Princess Diana,
she's not truly gone because she lives
on in Prince William and Prince Harry's
legacy because of her.
They both do charitable work and they
married for love instead of finding a mate
inside of the royal family,
and we're sure that if
she could see them today,
she would truly be proud.
So I hope you found
this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that.
Thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos
just like this twice a week,
so hit that subscribe button and you'll
learn all about those when they come
out.
And as always,
thank you for watching.